alors après j'ai appelé sa femme qui m'a
dit météo pas au courant tu es bien le
dernier ne pas être au courant que en
fait bas et on n'est plus ensemble
il est parti en malaisie il est hors de
question qu'on aille nous en malaisie
avec les enfants je dis ah bon d'accord
donc là je demande le divorce
voilà donc je dis bah écoute maintenant
il faut que tu ramènes que les enfants
reviennent alors là hors de question là
s'en est suivi qu'en fait il ya elle lui
on avait des billets en open
loria elle était là-bas il ya l'été là
bas où il va vite réalisé que quelque
chose ne va pas bah oui c'est sûr qu'est
ce qui se passe là bas j'ai tout de
suite vu qu'il voulait plus qu'on
communique avec mon père moi j'avais
déjà 14 ans j'avais déjà l'esprit clair
et j'avais tout de suite vu l'adultère
qui seraient entre lui et ma mère
d'accord mais c'est incroyable donc tu
es là bas il voit donc ta mère partir
avec un avec un autre homme
tu vois toi et voilà les frères et
soeurs et vous pouvez plus parler à
votre père était en malaisie à l'autre
bout à l'autre bout du monde
qu'est ce qui te passe par la tête à ce
moment là crie ben moi je voulais tout
de suite rentré
ouais nan tu veux dit ça comment tu veux
tu leur as tu l'as dit ça ta mère et ah
oui je leur ai dit il le savait que je
voulais rentrer bien sûr et il te disais
quoi bein il me disait que pour moi
j'allais il voulait après voulait pas du
tout que je rentre que je rentre à la
maison
d'accord pas du tout alors là tu
remarques que ta maman a une relation
avec ce remy daillet comment tu
remarques sarkis qui bat quand ils ont
commencé à coucher dans la même chambre
ah ouais c'est sûr c'est explicite et a
pu en parler à tu pouvais plus en parler
tu pouvais plus parler à ton père non du
tout aucune aucune relation moyens tu
pouvais même pas prendre un téléphone
essayé de l'appeler de rien du tout quoi
rien impossible alors tu comprend vite
qu'il veut pas que ton père vous
rejoigne
oui sinon malaisie donc là tu te dis que
tu viens et non un cauchemar c'est ça
comment tu as fait pour revenir alors on
avait pris des billets aller-retour et
donc je me suis dis et je me suis servi
du voyage retour pour rentrer en france
mais comment tu as fait tu étais tu t'es
sauvé un jour comment ça s'est passé
alors de ce que j'ai compris il ya eu
des échanges dans notre ma mère et mon
père mais oui sinon c'était en grande
partie ça il vous a maltraité d'abriter
oui moi j'ai été maltraité en malaisie
ça m'est déjà arrivé vu que je savais
qu'il y avait un adultère entre lui et
le maire que j'étais pas obéissant qui
me kim envoie bouler dehors dans
l'escalier de devant la maison
tim menace qui me frappe et ta mère à
gizeh rien non non non pour elle c'est
tellement utilisé c'est ça elle était
complètement sous son emprise c'était
c'est quelqu'un de vraiment manipulable
ma mère et et lui c'est un bon
manipulateur pour la coupe alors on
n'était pas scolarisé la main non létaux
faisait pas toute la journée moi j'étais
dehors je passais le moins de temps
possible avec ma mère ge avec ma mère et
mes façons je rentrais uniquement à midi
pour m'assurer que mes frères et soeurs
avait à manger
il paraît que vous n'aviez même pas à
manger parfois oui c'est ça parfois même
rémy ollier et mamère partait au
restaurant ils nous laissaient il
comptait sur le fait que je rentre à la
maison pour faire à manger à mes petits
frères et soeurs vous faire il n'était
pas là il devais avoir 6 ans oui et ça
mais ça m'est déjà arrivé de d'ouvrir
les placards de retrouver juste à vieux
paquet de riz tir incroyable et ils le
vivent le vivez comment votre frère
votre nom puisque vous avez plus de
bouffe du tout nouvel avenant du tout on
a eu les dernières nouvelles qu'on a eue
c'était il ya quatre semaines par une
journaliste de quoi elles ans pour qui
nous a envoyé les photos vous n'avez pas
pu vous enfuir avec va partir avec vous
non bah mon petit frère était beaucoup
trop petit et ma petite soeur elle était
c'était encore une petite fille à
l'aider croyant sa mère